[Applaus]
der harz von oben nach unten von ost
nach west
hier gab es dann auch am bahnübergang
diese stolper drehte für die flüchtlinge
wir brauchen früher militärisches
sperrgebiet heute beliebtes ausflugsziel
und für ihn schicksalsberg fast jeden
tag treibt es den 86 jährigen nach oben
also heute 8500 46 mal morgen 740 und
vom rammelsberg mit dem gleitschirm über
goslar
[Musik]
martin hinze bei der arbeit wenn jetzt
die schulter nach oben schießt dachte
dass der gott im gesamten ein bisschen
super von einer der längsten hänge
seilbrücken der welt befördert die
28-jährige besonders wagemutige in den
abgrund
das was jetzt gleich kommt ein
weihnachtsgeschenk von andrea für robert
extra aus berlin sind die beiden dafür
angereist
das gefühl es gibt auch nicht starten
weil die denn ich möchte uns reden und
fragt ihr auch die lust haben da kommt
kein ja kein nein und dann bauen wir die
auch wieder auf eine stufe nach vorne
die beiden jedenfalls wollen nicht
ausgebaut werden
ich habe ja schon einiges verrückt
gemacht aber das ist immer wieder an
überwindung fünf sekunden freier fall
und freier lauf angeführt
die rappbodetalsperre ist das outdoor
mekka für adrenalin fans von anfang an
haben zwei brüder aus dem harz an das
potenzial dieser strukturschwachen
regionen sachsen anhalt geglaubt zurecht
sich tausende pilgern mittlerweile das
ganze jahr hierher wollen spektakuläre
action in atemberaubender natur erleben
[Musik]
direkt neben der größten staumauer
deutschlands die hänge seilbrücke 458
frei hängende meter alles andere als ein
lockerer spaziergang
aber ich würde hier nicht springen
marien fertigt mittlerweile die nächsten
mutigen ab mit der doppel seilrutsche
der wega sippel 1
geht es superman gleich über den see
marien sichert beruhigt lacht erklärt
über 20 mal pro stunde
das gleiche
ja das ist wirklich ist also freude am
fußball das hier ist mein traumjob sagt
die harzer das ganz in der nähe der
eiserne vorhang einst deutschland teilte
das weiß die 28 jährige nur aus dem
geschichtsunterricht der harz madeline
unbelastete heimat so einige natürlich
auch mein alter wahnsinn weggegangen
ziemlich war es eigentlich hier
wegzugehen ich liebe meine familie und
ich auch dass ich kann es mir echt nicht
anders vorstellen es ist wie ein traum
der harz im dreiländereck zwischen
niedersachsen sachsen anhalt und
thüringen
wir reisen weiter durch den nationalpark
unser nächstes ziel der brocken
sagenumwoben und geschichtsträchtig
[Musik]
vor über 30 jahren leistete dietmar
schulte genau hier als ddr grenzsoldat
seinen wehrdienst der brocken war
militärisches sperrgebiet 28 jahre lang
durfte ihn kein normalbürger betreten
weder aus ost noch aus westdeutschland
[Musik]
heute bietet schuld wanderungen an
geschichtsunterricht sehr persönlich es
ist mit das was mich emotional am
meisten noch zu tränen rührt wenn ich
bilder von der maueröffnung sind einfach
immer noch ein konzentrieren noch unter
ja ich habe meine eigene gefangenschaft
bewacht sagt schildger für carolin rede
der ehemalige ddr grenzer von einer
anderen welt
dass ich das natürlich wahnsinnig krasse
dass man wirklich auch festgenommen
wurde dass man sie nicht rüber dürfte
also ich meine eigentlich was ja
irgendwie schon ein land und es war halt
geteilt
auch für benno schmidt ist der brocken
so was wie sein schicksal wie ein magnet
zieht der berg ihn an und immer wieder
hinauf heute das unglaubliche 8500 46
mal am 13 august 61 mit dem berliner
mauerbau wurde uns wanderung dieser
brocken genommen und das wir sehen ja
von wernigerode und das war immer ein
lieblings wanderziel und mit einmal ging
das nicht mehr 28 jahre durfte ich hier
nicht hoch habe ich mich 28 jahren
längst ist er als brocken benno weit
über die hans region hinaus bekannt drei
mal steht er mittlerweile im guinness
buch der rekorde und ans aufhören denkt
der 86 jährige noch lange nicht auch
eine vorbildfunktion anderen wir sind
jeden tag zur arbeit die kinder müssen
jeden tag zur schule und ich muss eben
jeden tag zehn wochen
dietmar schulte und seine wandergruppe
sind mittlerweile amecker loch
angekommen
hier hat sich wenn es geregnet hat immer
besonders ergiebig ergossen und die
alten ddr regen planen die haben die
nässe nicht abgedrückt nach einer stunde
ist das durch gesorgt durch die planer
und der soldat hat dann hier acht
stunden gekaut vor spurensuche an den
bäumen hier haben sich schulte und seine
genossen damals verewigt
schnitzereien als zeitdokument sagen die
ihren frust rausgelassen
die wunde ist noch nicht verheilt es ist
befreiend es zu erleben dass das heute
geschichte ist und das wird nie mehr
wiederkommen das ist eine krankheit die
man nie wieder kriegen kann aber es ist
gut sich zu erinnern dass man die
krankheit noch mal sich anschaut und
sagt dreimal holz das ist geschichte das
wird nicht mehr passieren brocken benno
ist mittlerweile am gipfel angekommen
der granitstein markiert die stelle wo
früher die mauer verlief
keine fünf minuten unter extrem wanderer
ist von fans umringt
denn der ist verbrennung wichtig als
sich hier am dritten dezember 89 die
mauer öffnete war benno dabei hier vor
dem tor hat man immer noch angst ich
habe mich nicht getraut für fotos machen
man dachte immer noch ein wird verhaftet
aber als erstes öffnete und wir dann
hoch strömenden habe ich den ganzen
apparat folge knipst und jedes jedes mal
wenn ich hier vorbeikommen jeden tag
denke ich an diese stünden der eröffnung
dieses braucht drei stunden lang vom tal
bis zum gipfel lässt dietmar schulte
eine zeit wieder lebendig werden die
schon so lange vergangen scheint und
doch sein leben bis heute so sehr prägt
hier ist neben nena vom brocken blick
rahmen schwarzes schäferhündin von der
hundestaffel die haben halt verstärkt
hunde gesucht und eben auch bei privaten
züchtern das angekauft die tiere und mit
der bin ich hier dann immer streife die
brückenstraße hungen runter gelaufen
dieselbe straße eine ganz andere welt
der gipfel für den jungen grenzer damals
unerreichbar bisher ungefähr konnte ich
denn als grenzsoldat drauf hier war dann
die brocken mauer vor
die segmente waren identisch mit den
mauer segmenten von der berliner mauer
die ding dann hier rum und wir als
grenzer durften dann praktisch immer nur
um die brocken mauer auf der kuppe
rumlaufen das war dann hier eine art
geschlossene insel heute ist das broken
plateau für dietmar schulte der gipfel
der freiheit
wir reisen weiter richtung süden entlang
dem harzer grenzweg frühere
todesstreifen heute wanderweg durch die
weitgehend unberührte natur des harzer
nationalpark nur ein paar kilometer
weiter liegt benneckenstein und die
waldbühne jannik liebe tod ist wenigen
steiner und probt hier den sturm
der 38-jährige regisseur hat in den usa
studiert an verschiedenen national
theater inszeniert lebt in berlin
vor drei jahren hat yannick liebe truth
das theater natur festival ins leben
gerufen
modernes theater mitten im harz da sind
wirklich zwei welten die aufeinander
prallen hier die arbeit mit den
schauspielern auf professioneller ebene
und dann die benninger steiner die mich
als kleinen jungen sehen das ist nur
chance hierfür diese bühne ist nicht
jemand von außen war der jetzt irgendwas
mit der bühne macht sondern es ist der
kleine junge aus dem ort der hier jetzt
theater macht zu setzen
[Musik]
jan hasenfuß und lena stamm standen
gerade für spielfilmproduktionen fürs
zdf vor der kamera
dann kam liebe tod angebot auf der walze
spielen
er spricht unsere sprache weil sie von
außen quasi gelernt hat aber die sprache
die hier zu sprechen ist die hat er
natürlich aufgesogen und zeigt uns was
hier läuft und das bringt er zusammen
das wichtigste ist dass man hat die
leute abholt und das kann glaube ich ja
nicht sehr gut weil didier lockwood weil
der die leute kennt
premieren abend shakespeare als
multimediale neuinterpretation das land
sachsen anhalt fördert das
theaterfestival mit 40.000 euro
sie sparen will so kunst und kultur im
ländlichen raum stärken
jannik liebe tod ist aufgeregt muss ich
auf die bühne unter den hier eröffnen
es ist durchaus anspruchsvolles
sommertheater razzia mit liebe tod
seinem publikum bietet alte menschen die
an den rand der gesellschaft gedrängt
werden abwanderung der jungen themen die
man auch hier im harz gut kennt ja erst
mal musste man sich ein bisschen daran
gewöhnen aber dann wenn man sich da so
ein rein gefuchst hat denn das ganze ist
schon in ordnung
ganz klasse choreografie also
unglaublich was hier so
und weiter geht unsere reise richtung
nordwesten
ein letztes mal überqueren wir die
ehemalige deutsch-deutsche grenze und
landen in goslar die mittelalterliche
altstadt gehört zum unesco
weltkulturerbe
auf nur einem quadratkilometer reihen
sich 1500 fachwerkhäuser aneinander und
in der kaiserpfalz wurde über 200 jahre
lang deutsche geschichte geschrieben
hier ist familie hoffmeister zu hause
carsten ist in goslar aufgewachsen und
viel in der welt herumgekommen
vor zwei jahren ist er mit seiner frau
und sohn matti zurück nach goslar
gezogen der ingenieur brauchte keine
großen überredungskünste um annika von
goslar zu überzeugen
[Musik]
wir haben es aber auch schnell in der
natur also man hat die berge immer
hinsicht
das ist auch das schöne man hat so weit
kommen aus den bergen also ist den alpen
her gezogen und haben einen flug berg
vor der tür also sonst kann man im
norden nicht fliegen wirklich und
außerhalb finden oder sowas aber hier
ist es so man kann bei gutem wetter
einfach losgehen und das nach 40 minuten
auf dem berg und fliegt unter das ist
schon sehr schön
gleitschirmfliegen die große
leidenschaft der beiden kassen und
annika haben sich beim fliegen
kennengelernt und ineinander verliebt
bei nordwestwind kennen beide nur ein
ziel den rammelsberg jetzt schon vier
jahre aber ein bisschen aufregung ist
man dabei aber eher freudige aufregung
carsten startet zuerst
springt rein in den wind und steigt auf
über wasser
die thermik man spürt den wind man
schaltet wenn man hier auf dreht dann
kann man über den harz gucken das ist
einfach so dann fliegt annika los vieles
verbindet der harz miteinander
lebensfreude und kultur vergangenheit
und zukunft der puls der region eher
ruhig als hektisch die menschen fühlen
sich angezogen von dieser ganz eigene
mischung haben die annika und carsten
vier ihre mitte gefunden
wer in den herz kommt wird das spüren
[Musik]